hello and welcome to game life's weekly
rundown of the video games you are going
to be blowing all of your money on over
the next seven days
oh my god you guys it's finally here
after years of waiting ken levine's
bioshock infinite his follow-up to the
amazing 2007 game bioshock is coming out
this week but it's not the only video
game you should be aware of what am i
talking about let's find out
okay well sure first we'll just talk
about bioshock infinite obviously i'm
sure i'm not alone when i say the
original bioshock said in the underwater
dystopia of rapture is one of my
favorite games of all time now i
recently got the chance to play the
first four hours of bioshock infinite
and it was awesome while it has the same
general themes it's a totally new world
with new characters new gameplay you
explore the gorgeous floating city of
colombia rescue a girl named elizabeth
who has mysterious time travel powers
and basically you just try to stay alive
while figuring out what the heck is up
with this place you can delve into the
mystery of bioshock infinite yourself on
march 26th
now bioshock infinite is a single player
only game and if you're looking for a
cooperative shooter experience you might
try army of two the devil's cartel also
coming out on march 26th you can play
army of two solo but this shooter series
is built around its signature two-player
cooperative mode and yes you can play it
in local split screen if you want to
share some fist bumps on the couch
instead of virtual fist bumps over xbox
live
but army of two is not what i meant when
i said there's another game you need to
know about on march 28th nintendo will
release the unassuming looking
downloadable game hormone knight for the
3ds now harmonite is from game freak the
company that makes pokemon but it's
nothing like those games it's an
innovative musical platformer you're
running to the right jumping over gaps
collecting items and hitting enemies but
you're doing all of it to the rhythm of
the music if you lose the beat
everything falls apart
i played all the way through the
japanese version when it came out last
year and i loved it the music is really
catchy and the levels can be insanely
challenging even if you're good at music
games harmonite is a full length game
that is a steal at a 15 price point and
that's it for this week in video game
releases for more head to wired.com
game life
you